circa tre anni fa
ho la fortuna di cominciare ad
incontrare delle persone veramente
speciali entrare in delle storie fuori
dal comune
storie di persone con patologie gravi
spesso incurabili storia dei loro angeli
custodi mogli mariti figli genitori ma
anche medici assistenti che si prendono
cura di loro storie di sofferenza ma
anche dove si respira tantissimo amore
pazienti con patologie come la sla una
patologia neurodegenerativa
ma anche tetraplegie di natura ischemica
o con conseguenze da traumi avrete
sicuramente visto in qualche caso avrete
le immagini di qualche paziente in
situazioni di cosiddetto lockedin ovvero
completamente immobile incapace di
parlare ma che tramite l'ausilio di
tecnologie come ad esempio il puntatore
oculare interagisce tramite il computer
con le persone con l'ambiente
bene ci sono delle persone che non
possono utilizzare queste tecnologie è
su queste che ci siamo concentrati e
alcuni di questi da alcuni mesi hanno
potuto riprendere a comunicare dopo mesi
o anni è stato possibile grazie a una
tecnologia che si chiama brain computer
interface
la tecnologia che consente di
intercettare l'attività elettrica sulla
corteccia celebrale tramite dei sensori
elettroencefalografici e in
corrispondenza determinati pensieri
poter utilizzare questi stimoli per
controllare da un computer una
tecnologia a cui mi sono avvicinato
circa sei anni fa e che all'inizio mi è
sembrato come una sorta di bestia
indomabile
perché 20 anni di ricerche però aveva
prodotto dei laboratori
dei prototipi per so che limitati
all'interno delle mura di laboratorio
però mi sono convinto di questa risorsa
formidabile sebbene complessa da queste
risorse si potrà si potesse tirar fuori
qualcosa di utile disabile per perlomeno
per pazienti in queste situazioni ed è
lì che è cominciato questo percorso
percorso di studio che ha portato a
un'analisi di fattibilità dei prototipi
e ea individuare un particolare filone
quello che sfrutta delle immagini di
movimento quando noi pensiamo di muovere
le nostre mani o le gambe in avanti
indietro a destra e sinistra il pensiero
che anticipa il movimento stesso quindi
si sa che noi siamo poi in grado o meno
di muovere i nostri arti questa questa
attività celebrale che si viene a creare
può essere intercettata e sfruttato con
una sorta di joystick mentale quindi un
joystick mentale per controllare dei
dispositivi assis tv la carrozzina
elettrica
il controllo della domotica delle luci
quindi l'ambiente più in generale ma
anche la comunicazione quindi tramite la
sintesi vocale e così via
mi faccio adesso vedere un video in cui
ci siamo focalizzati e proprio sulla
comunicazione in quanto facendo un
analisi di quelle che potevano essere le
priorità da dare allo sviluppo
quello che è emerso è stato ovviamente
pensiamo al caso della sla una patologia
emblematica è veramente crudele in cui
si perde il controllo dei muscoli
progressivamente quindi questo va
impattare inizialmente sugli stili di
vita e quindi nell'interazione con i
propri cari con i propri familiari
andando avanti anche l'autonomia nel
nutrirsi nel respirare viene meno ma
addirittura dall'impossibilità di
muovere le palpebre ne determina anche
l'incapacità di rivedere di osservare di
guardare ora noi le nostre necessità per
sopravvivere sono sicuramente
alimentarsi sicuramente respirare ma la
comunicazione è fondamentale
noi abbiamo bisogno di relazionarci con
gli altri e quindi è emerso chiaro che
la comunicazione del primo passo su cui
bisognava lavorare
quello che il video che vi faccio vedere
è focalizzato sulla comunicazione è una
tecnologia siamo rientra fra le
tecnologie di comunicazione aumentativa
alternativa e con un'interazione
estremamente semplice perché da questo
si doveva partire e vedrete ci sono
anche dei feedback audio che consentono
per l'appunto a persone che non possono
guardare lo schermo di poter essere
guidate in questo tipologia di supporto
vediamo il video speciale che migliasso
qui c'è un semplice un selettore di
risposte si no non lo so da cui
generalmente cominciamo quindi come il
primo passo che semplice
bene in questo secondo caso è una
griglia un po più articolata quindi con
una maggiore libertà di espressione più
livelli per aumentare un po la
possibilità di interazione
ebbene questa sebbene semplice
interazione ha consentito negli ultimi
mesi ai dei pazienti che non avevano
delle alternative per poter comunicare
di poter comunicare i propri bisogni
proprie necessità anche malesseri e
alcuni casi potrei raccontarvi vari
aneddoti quello è sicuramente a cui più
sono affezionato quello di un signore
che da sei anni nello che dean non si
sapeva non si ha la certezza di quale
fosse il suo stato cognitivo poiché non
era in grado di dare the feedback
dopo due sessioni di training ha
cominciato a darci delle conferme a
rispondere in modo preciso a delle
domande è una delle prime cose che
abbiamo chiesto e aprendogli le palpebre
serre in grado di vedere ha detto di sì
ha visto per la prima volta il nipote di
5 anni
potete immaginare che emozione ma c'è
ce ne sarebbero tanti altri un padre che
ha potuto per la prima volta dire un
ciao alla propria figlia di 4 anni in
quanto in quel periodo della sua nascita
era entrata in questa situazione di
incapacità di comunicare
quindi è solo il primo passo sicuramente
stiamo lavorando su controlli più
avanzati stiamo lavorando anche sulla
robotica esoscheletri robot umanoidi
anche cose un po più futuristiche però
era un passo importante da compiere
queste le immagini a cui sono
affezionato e sausalito in california
un'immagine una foto ho scattato due
anni fa
sullo sfondo san francisco in primo
piano dei sassi in equilibrio uno
sull'altro che un signore dai tratti
orientali metteva lì sulla spiaggia e
che in quel momento questa precarietà di
questi sassi a volte ci si poggiavano
dei gabbiani e facendoli cadere ma non
sempre
alcune volte inspiegabilmente rimanevano
ancora in piedi mia mi ha riportato
l'immagine di questi pazienti dello
stato di queste persone con cui era
entrato in contatto una precarietà
quotidiana legata proprio alle polvere
della malattia però è nata in me la
convinzione che un'idea può essere
incisiva al punto di cambiare un destino
che sembra segnato
pensate a questi pazienti che arrivano a
giorno dopo giorno consapevole del quale
l'evoluzione della malattia e quale
doveva essere il loro il loro percorso
il loro destino e quindi come si può
cambiare un flusso di un corso d'acqua è
possibile cambiare delle storie l'acqua
che ritroviamo in quest'altra immagine
l'immagine dei bottini di siena se nella
città la mia città adottiva i bottini
sono un'opera
ingegnosa e maestosa sono 25 chilometri
di cunicoli sotterranei dove l'acqua
scorre per gravità scorre grazie una
percettibile pendenza passa attraverso
delle vasche di decantazione dei filtri
fino ad arrivare alle fonti
un'opera che nel xvi secolo ha
consentito a questa città di svilupparsi
di prosperare pure in assenza di
sorgenti naturali per corsi d'acqua
naturali cosa che era indispensabile a
quel tempo
ebbene qui ci vedo come un idea
combinata con l'ingegno con la
determinazione può cambiare la storia e
voglio finire con un altro video un
video divertente che che testimonia
senz'altro il potenziale della di questa
tecnologia
è
grazie